[Music]
very important thing I told my daughter
and granddaughters no serious guys were
30. okay and what no serious guys to
your 30s
dear president and I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it's October 17
2022 and no you're not having some sort
of medical emergency this is a special
happy hour edition of the Reuben report
uh this morning at 11 A.M Eastern when
we normally tape this show I was over in
Wynwood which is a suburb of Miami a
very cool hip spot they say that's where
we opened up the locals offices and I
was interviewing Miami mayor Francis
Suarez which we're going to put up
tomorrow and throughout the week so we
couldn't do the Regular Show then and I
said we cannot give up a day we must
connect with the people we want to talk
to them get some questions from them do
our thing so we are here for a happy
hour show I've got tequila right over
here I'm going to show you that in just
a second we are going to do one story up
top because I couldn't let this fouchy
stuff slide but real quick on this on
this Biden thing and the hair sniffing
and the so he he said to his uh what
granddaughter and niece that you don't
have any serious guys till you're 30. is
the implication they should just have
one night stands like they should
basically just get banged by a whole
bunch of dudes until they're 30. and
then they should get serious wouldn't
you be saying you should only have a
serious boyfriend when you're 20. that
might you might want to try a real
relationship no nothing serious till
then gang bangs whatever you need people
it's happy hour it's happy hour what can
I tell you uh so yes we're going to talk
about Lord fauci real quick and then we
are going to mix it up and uh and do
some fun stuff I'm not even wearing a
jacket today it's very casual very
casual here I'm free balling too
oh now we're demonetized uh let me talk
to you guys about bully and Max real
quick then we'll get to it you know as
uh inflation surpasses high as not seen
in 40 years the value of the dollar is
decreasing with every passing day you're
paying more at the pump the grocery
store for cars for housing face it your
paper money is worth less friends the
timing couldn't be any better for our
new sponsor bullion Max Boolean Max is a
direct to Consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security for you and
your family in times of Crisis here's
why I love bully and max they're owned
by veterans in the precious metal space
offer some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website I want to
help you get started so I worked out a
special offer with them just for you get
bullion Max's silver starter kit at
employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com Dave this kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including a silver
American eagle and a silver Australian
kangaroo this offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com Dave and now back to me
okay before we get to the drinking
let's talk to talk about a man who could
drive you to drink yes that's Anthony
fauci uh because he's making the media
rounds again and he's basically lying
about absolutely everything that he had
to do with during the two years of covet
whether it was vaccines lockdowns school
closures kicking people out of work all
he's just name a thing he's lying about
it here is fauci just uh I believe this
is yesterday saying that he had nothing
to do with school closures was it a
mistake in so many states in so many
localities uh to see schools closed as
long as they were I think in some case I
don't want to use the word mistake John
because if I do it gets taken out of the
context that you're asking me the
question on well but it was going to be
too high a price yeah I would say that
what we should realize and have realized
that there will be deleterious
collateral consequences when you do
something like that this idea that this
virus doesn't afflict children is not so
it does we've lost close to 1500 kids so
far but much less than the older
population obviously oh of course but
you shouldn't discount that it does
afflict children so it isn't without
consequences if you go back and I ask
anybody to go back over the number of
times that I've said we've got to do
everything we can to keep the schools
open no one plays that clip they always
come back and say fauci was responsible
for closing schools I had nothing to do
I mean let's get down to the effect
all right people you're ready because
we've got the internet this is
incredible so Connor over here sits in
front of this box and it's got light
coming out of it it's got wires going
into it he tells me it's connected to
this thing called the internet where you
can find video of people saying the
reverse thing for two years that he just
said right there he says he had nothing
to do with it he was trying to keep
schools open he didn't want to close
them
bouncy if we get community-based cases
throughout various parts of the country
then you use that information to make
decision if they're going to do what you
said which is do the kind of social
distancing that includes teleworking
closing schools Etc by the time we get
to the fall that we will have this under
control enough that it certainly will
not be the way it is now where people
are shutting schools my optimistic side
tells me that we'll be able to renew to
a certain extent but it's going to be
different remember now because this is
not going to disappear so we're going to
have to have in place the capability of
doing the things that we talk about all
the time on this stage to identify to
isolate to contact Trace so if you at
least agree that the general principle
is to try as best as you can to get the
children back to school I think you have
to put that in the context that an
important issue in that is to make sure
you do whatever you can to safeguard the
safety and the health of the children as
well as the teachers and that should
guide your policy
see as a father if I could just say I
would be delighted to send my kids back
to school I mean remote learning is
horrible especially for younger kids
it's just
it's just not the way the kids are
supposed to learn
Gall of this man this liar of course he
wanted schools closed and of course
there's plenty evidence of it but he
just keeps lying and keeps lying also he
says he had nothing to do with lockdowns
it wasn't just school closures he also
had nothing to do with lockdowns well
you're not going to believe it we found
this
do you regret particularly the last one
the shutdown the sweeping shutdown that
some said made things worse no I I I
don't uh Neil and in fact I think we
need to make sure that your listeners
understand
I didn't shut down anything I
recommended to the president that we
shut the country down and the only way
to do that is by Draconian means of
essentially shutting down a country we
know that we can do that if we shut down
well I think one of the things you
really need to do to the extent
that you can shut down
temporarily the country I think is
important Well if I knew at the time
that
shutting down would have such a dramatic
effect on controlling the spread
obviously we would have shut down
earlier there were those who say you
shut down your destructive things by
disrupting the economy and others say
well if you save so many infections by
shutting down why didn't you shut down
two weeks earlier these people it's just
incredible like I I wanted to be studied
how it's not that people can't be wrong
about things of course people could be
wrong about things it's that they can
lie about everything they used to say
and believe not only is he saying I had
nothing to do with lockdowns and then
we're showing you all the lockdown
evidence but he's also at times saying
that he would have been for more
lockdowns the lockdown there's no
evidence that any of it worked it all
actually had far more detrimental
effects when it came to depression and
alcoholism and physical abuse and kids
with slow speech and all of these things
all of the horrific things that they
have done that many of them we probably
won't even see the effects of for years
and years and years as young people grow
up delayed speech all of the stuff guys
all of it he had everything to do with
it and now he's on a PR tour making sure
that you don't know what you know but
Anthony fauci I'm not going to let you
get away with it not on this happy hour
and on this happy hour I think it's time
now that I've got the fresh bottle of
class Azul this is the tequila that I
love I also have a nice glass there with
one one rock I like the one rock the
nice one rock can we get more into the
happy hour mood would that be possible
here in oh look at that that is
absolutely incredible how did we do that
we are now in Miami happy hour mode this
is a fresh model I just took the plastic
off of the class Azul Reposado
which I absolutely love a lot of you are
asking about this bottle because this is
the bottle of tequila that I had at the
uh at the Bill Maher Club random podcast
a couple days ago and uh
what you may have noticed if those for
so for some of you that are real tequila
people playing at home so I had asked
them to get me this they said what do
you drink and I said I like the class
Azul uh Reposado and they said well
actually he usually drinks uh Don Julio
1942 and I was like well you did ask me
what I like and I do like that and to
their credit they got me the bottle that
I like what I needed to find out I got a
text Bill and find out what's what here
he had a special bottle this is the
emblem that's normally on here his
bottle if you watch the video had a
special almost like a square like emblem
I got to find out what that was you know
he's got that HBO money so he can figure
out uh what's going on here uh anyway uh
cheers everybody hope you're having a
drink at home for those of you that are
watching on locals I will be taking some
questions on the Fly I have nothing in
front of me I have some fouchy papers
but I've got nothing else in advance and
we're just here to to shoot the [ __ ] and
enjoy this Monday I feel like a Monday
happy hour was uh was the right way to
go so let me get a sip of this
foreign
man that is good that is good have I
turned you guys I definitely you were
always into the Tequila Phoenix you're
coming around on the tequila right
you're getting there and you Connor with
your monkey shoulder whiskey it's all he
drinks monkey shoulder you know about
this he's got to have it at all times
right before we start the show
um anyway I thought maybe I'd talk a
little bit about what it's been like to
be back on the grid because it's been
about it's about 45 days here and a lot
has changed uh not only while I was off
the grid but then since I have come back
on the grid uh when I was off the grid
well we had our first son uh Justin who
is now just over two months born on
August 6th and uh he's just awesome this
kid is he's just great like he's just a
Smiler and a laugher a little gassy
there's gonna there's gonna be some gas
that I think that's to be uh to be
understood
um but uh he's just great and especially
now that he's like smiling a little bit
more when you know directly you know
usually when kids are born at first
something you get these smiles and their
eyes are kind of they can't really focus
on things and they can only see a little
bit of distance at first and then
literally every day it increases and
increases now at about nine weeks like
he's recognizing me a little bit more
he's smiling like directly I'm doing all
my little silly games and voices and I
tell them about politics and all the
stuff
um so we're enjoying ourselves and now
and then Luke
arrived what it's about it's about 10 or
11 days ago uh we got number two and uh
and Luke who again as I told you guys uh
he is not named after Luke Skywalker he
is named after Uncle Lucas played by
Leslie Nielsen in the season finale of
Golden Girls of course he married
Dorothy's bornak Uncle of Blanche
Devereaux you you all know the story I
don't have to drive that thing home uh
but he's been great and you know so far
so far so good you know we're a little
little short on sleep uh meals are a
little more interrupted these days but
life is good and it's it's given me I
would say Like A Renewed fervor for all
of this you know I'm obviously very
passionate about what I do and I I
believe in in fighting for a better
world and trying to make things a little
bit better you know there's as Jared
Kushner said to me in our interview you
know the machine is the machine and you
got to learn how to play the game well
it's sort of like the machine has
existed long before me and long after me
but if you can if you can make it a
little bit better in your brief little
blip on Earth then I think you've done
something good and since I have these
two kids I'm feeling like this yeah it's
this renewed call to uh to keep fighting
uh for for some of the things that we're
fighting for so uh it's been a wild not
only wild 45 days I would say in the
what are we we're at about nine months
now that we've been here in Florida and
obviously Florida has been well to you
to you Florida I should drink every time
fauci lies be under the table
that is good if you if you like tequila
it's not cheap it's not cheap so a
bottle of this stuff it's probably about
150 bucks it is not cheap I'm just
putting that out there so it's a it's a
luxury item uh but it is worth it you
have one sip of this and uh your life
will change that's what I'm telling you
um but you know so we've been in in
Florida for about nine months now and
um you know well you guys know I I had
to get out of Los Angeles and I'll put a
little money in the jar I'm running out
of I'm running out of Cold Hard Cash
here we're gonna have to go to the bank
um I had to get out of LA and it's just
it's been so great here that this
morning when we taped this interview
with mayor Suarez I was reminded that it
was it was about 15 months or so ago
that I had interviewed him for the first
time in Miami on location in Miami Beach
uh it was in June of last year I wasn't
even thinking about moving to to Florida
yet you know there was like an inkling
of it but I really wanted to see what
happened with the with the recall and
all that
um and just how quickly time flies like
15 months later we're here for nine
months you know I'm doing stuff not only
with the mayor but with the governor
I've been so welcomed here like life is
good covet is irrelevant here the
economy is booming I meet so many great
people here like it's just uh well I
guess I guess the point is that if you
if you do some good work and you keep
your head on straight you make decisions
that are good for you and your family
then then some good things can happen
we'll we'll have the locals Community
throw in a couple a couple questions and
comments that I will get to uh but oh I
should also mention uh because of the uh
because of the tequila here and
obviously the big thing of of last week
was the mar interview I think we're on
to something here
I think we're on to something here and
then I think that that was really what
came across to me uh in the comments
more than anything else look a lot of
you it was all over the place the
comments and that's that's how you know
you're doing something good right so if
I put up a video and everyone agrees
with me
every single person agrees with me and
you got to remember some people hate
watch some people watch because they're
big fans some people are in between and
also the people that comment are only a
certain set of people so you know if a
video gets 500 000 views and ten
thousand people comment on it that seems
like a lot but that means 490
000 people did not comment on it might
have just enjoyed it and walked away
that's why the comment system the way it
exists now is so disregulating because
it's very hard to get a snapshot of what
reality is because you're getting from a
certain set of people that do comment in
the first place I like a lot of
commenters a lot of them have really
great thoughts and can help me frame a
story or an idea or give me some new
thoughts whatever it might be but it is
sort of an odd selection to like just go
about your day thinking well what are
the commenters say because you don't
know what all the people who watched it
and thought nice things or bad things or
whatever else might be what's on their
mind uh anyway one of the interesting
things about the mar interview and he's
he's said this to me now since since uh
we sat down is that our audiences are
kind of all over the place right so he's
got the more liberal audience now and if
you would have said to me Dave you know
if you would have said to me 10 years
ago Dave you're gonna have a sit down
with Bill Maher you're going to be
drinking tequila and smoking weed you're
going to be the conservative he's going
to be the liberal like it's all over the
place right but he said that his
audience really really has been loving
it and I've looked on the comments over
there and and yeah some of them think
I'm I'm too much of a trump supporter or
I'm a scarier conservative or something
like that but the bulk of them and this
is a credit's bill
the bulk of them were like hey Reuben
seems cool like they disagree on some
stuff but they're enjoying having a
drink with each other this is what we
all used to do right this is what we
used to enjoy about each other that
you'd sit down and you'd break bread or
drink tequila with somebody who who you
don't agree on everything with and the
way that we kind of danced in and out of
politics and everything else as for my
audience you guys said something very
similar I think a certain percentage of
you and I fully get it you wanted me to
hit him a little bit harder on the
politics stuff but as I said right
before the interview and you can go back
and watch the day before I left for Los
Angeles
you know I you had to I think that I had
to have a strategic goal going into this
my strategic goal was hey let's start
the conversation right let's see if we
can find some common ground here and
we're not going to solve it all in one
day like the chances that I was going to
walk into Bill Maher's house
like knock him out and now you'll vote
Republican and support DeSantis like the
chances that were going to happen were
basically zero so we had to do a dance
together and by the way the chances that
he was gonna like knock me out and be
like and see you were wrong about voting
for Trump and yo you you should vote for
well I don't even know what Democrat he
could support but you get the point and
I think we both kind of realized that
early on into his credit they didn't
want to make it all about politics and
we did we did the thing and and I think
that there's some richness in there and
if we can only just revert to that right
if we can just revert to hey I'm willing
to have a drink with somebody I disagree
with and have those conversations and
then and that's why I keep talking about
the post-woke world and how we have to
map it now right if we can get out of
this thing like let's say the
Republicans really do well and take the
Senate and the house win some of these
gubernatorial races Biden becomes
complete lame duck I mean he's just lame
in general but he becomes complete lame
duck and then we realize boy there's
there's really an Avenue now it's not
Republicans are so great it really isn't
but maybe we're not going to have these
crazy crazy crazy spending bills maybe
we're not going to look to chop every
child's genitals off maybe we're going
to get a little of the neo-racism out of
the schools and then we just start
getting a little bit normal a little bit
normalized because the machine will go
whoa the people have spoken we may not
like what they're saying but they have
spoken and maybe the machine starts kind
of recalibrating right in front of us
and then we just all are like all right
okay things are a little bit more normal
we kind of like normal maybe we took
normal for granted I mean maybe we all
did right if all of us had a time
machine
you could just snap right you could just
snap and go back to three years ago I
think a lot of people would do it you
know before all of this craziness yeah a
lot of it was on the way and the woke
stuff yeah look I was talking about the
woke stuff for a year so it's not that
it wasn't coming but before the covid
nonsense before like everything went
completely haywire and we talking about
World War III and Ukraine and all of
those things so I think we have to start
mapping what that would look like and
show people hey
conservatives used to talk to liberals
liberals used to talk to conservatives
we have to get rid of the walksters sure
we have to get rid of we have to get rid
of the really crazies over there uh
whatever whatever Fringe crazies exist
on the right I keep saying they have no
institutional power but if there's this
real racist movement on the right
something like that we would have to get
rid of that and then the bulk of us the
80 of us will just have at it like we
used to and that would be fully in the
spirit of America so that is the goal as
I sit here drinking tequila on this
happy hour uh with you
and of course what goes hand in hand
with that is that we just have to keep
building new things because a I could be
wrong maybe we don't get to the other
side B maybe even we do get to the other
side but they keep trying to destroy so
the most of us get to the other side but
these guys aren't going to stop they're
not just going to go away right and that
was always the risk of calling everyone
Hitler and Nazis you don't just stop one
day so we still have to build new things
that's what we're trying to do with uh
with Rumble and locals trying is not the
right word that's what we actually are
doing uh with Rumble and locals and and
we just have to find new ways to do
almost everything let me get to a couple
comments and questions and I'm curious
what you guys are drinking so let me
know what you good people are drinking
or perhaps participating in some other
activity right now I don't know what
you're doing uh but let us know I don't
know what that meant that definitely
didn't seem right uh mad says I have a
new mixed drink Arnold Palmer with a
nice shot of rum think I will make one
for this occasion I like that well first
off I love the Arnold Palmer you give me
half iced tea half lemonade I'm very
happy and then you put a little rum in
there that's very nice although I'm a
tequila guy
I do enjoy rum you know rum is going to
kind of gonna feel a little more
you know it's a little more like I guess
Jimmy buffetty kind of rum tequila is
going to kind of keep you up a little
bit more you can really get into it
politically with a friend over tequila
rum is a little more of enjoy yourself
It's Five O'Clock Somewhere kind of
thing uh EK says what is your
myers-brigg personality type geez
I don't know that I took one I think you
know I've taken the Jordan personality
test and I've taken some others over the
years what what are the other four
therefore I actually don't even know I
should do one and we'll we'll do the
results you know what I'm gonna do one
and we'll do the results I think I did
it maybe maybe 15 years ago or something
like that it's been a long time uh let's
see uh Nick says do you know if Spencer
Clavin is jealous uh at all that Justin
stole the show uh by being born on the
exact same day that he and Josh got
married so Spencer Cleveland of course
you guys uh should should all know
Spencer Spencer is a is a I think he is
a massive rising star in whatever this
online right leaning semi-sane group of
people is uh he is a great dude and he
and his now husband Josh were getting
married on October 6th I was supposed to
give the big speech at the wedding and I
was very excited to do it and I had
warned him we got a baby coming I don't
know if I'm going to be able to make it
and I hope that you won't hold that
against me and yes of course Justin was
born that very day I don't know that
he's jealous or angry I think we've been
able to bury the hatchet and uh I think
we will uh we'll be able to continue a
friendship despite having a baby on the
day of his wedded bliss
Amy Says in the spirit of Halloween how
do you feel about family costumes well
you know we do have our first Halloween
coming up and Daphne I believe there's
been some discussion about what the
family could be for Halloween do we want
to tip anything off do you know anything
I don't know Daphne's been working on
some things and Halloween is your
holiday you love horror you love
Halloween
um there are some options we've we've
discussed a couple things I don't want
to give anything away right now just
because yeah I think we should we'll
need to post some pictures but I do have
to say this one thing that has been very
refreshing and I think this is
completely uh indicative of what's going
on here in Florida and and maybe to some
extent this is a Miami thing or
something
um the last couple years I was in LA
almost nobody was putting out uh
pumpkins anymore you saw very few
witches maybe if Nancy Pelosi was in
town but you didn't see a lot of stuff
out there celebrating the Halloween
spirit there's a lot of Halloween spirit
out here I got witch's feet upside down
the neighbors Clyde was going crazy
because there were crows around witch's
feet turned out to be totally fake but
there's Halloween spirit about about
here which is also interesting because
it you know the fall here I'm from the
Northeast where the fall you know you
have to put out a jacket here I'm like
wandering around in a tank top and and
it's the fall
but I'll survive uh RB says have you and
David thought about writing a book about
your parenting experiences uh I don't
know that we're experts just yet in that
we are nine weeks into this thing but I
think we're doing I would say I think
we're doing a pretty good job like
David's reading all the books he's
talking to the right people about advice
he's uh
he's a little more patient I will tell
you something that has happened to me in
my in my middle age at 46 years old one
thing I've noticed is I am becoming very
sensitive to loud sounds I can't deal
with screaming and sometimes these kids
you know there's a screaming and a
crying and it can get pretty high
pitched I think usually my feeling
always is the high-pitched ones are gas
pains I don't know if that's based in
fact the fact checkers can be all over
me on that one
um but with like the real high-pitched
screaming like I want to be there to
soothe these kids and I'm I really am
trying my best and I'll have them laying
on my stomach pick them up and you know
we're doing all the put them on the
dockatot and doing all the stuff
um but David really has like absolutely
shined this is you know he was the one
that really was sort of sort of pushing
us towards this in the first place and
uh you know I think he just was so
absolutely ready for this and we've got
his mom and his sister have been with us
so we've had that female influence
around which obviously a lot of people
have asked about and I do think that
having female influence around actually
is important and I do also accept that
there are some people who look at the
traditional family which usually had a
mother a female and a father a male and
a certain amount of children and that is
what the prototypical family can look
like but I think you can map something
that's roughly approximate to that and
good that's that's my hypothesis I
suppose and that's what we're trying to
do here I don't have a lot of evidence
for that actually and I know this is
where the Media Matters losers who are
watching or go Dave Rubin doesn't think
gay families are good and of course
that's not true we there are no two kids
on Earth who have gotten more love since
these two kids have been born than us
than this family and those two kids
um but you know it's hard to map that
thing we do have a couple now I've met a
few gay families gay parents with kids
and we're trying to I think everyone's
just kind of feeling it out and like you
do things a little bit differently and
you know it's it's a different thing
um but it can be a great thing and I
think that that's what we're uh we're
trying to figure out fire says how was
the bris so we did have the briss on the
eighth day as has been prescribed in the
Torah and we had them oil come here I
watched the episode of Seinfeld with the
Moyle the night before to prepare myself
for that and then actually it's the same
oil
who did our first brisk a couple weeks
ago turns out that the Moyle plays
basketball and now I'm playing
basketball with Moyle on Tuesday nights
which really sounds like an episode of
Seinfeld you know I'm playing basketball
that's what happens in middle age one
year middle age I guess you're in your
20s everything seems cool one day you're
playing basketball with them oil you go
what happened what happened to me I
don't know
um suffice to say playing basketball I
got three braces now I've got the ace
bandage I've got the knee sleeve and
then I've got that metal freaking thing
and I'm actually praying playing pretty
well which is nice uh but the the brisk
was nice you know it's um well nice I
don't know if nice is the word you know
that they're doing a circumcision at a
Brisk you guys know that right yeah
that's why I gave you off that day um it
was on Friday
um yeah you know it's it's one of those
things I discussed it actually with
Dennis Prager if you haven't seen my
interview from a couple weeks ago you
know that this is a tradition that the
people that I come from have done for
literally thousands of years three
thousand some odd years of doing this
and it represents the Covenant with God
and all of those things there is a part
of me that's like well why would I have
to do that and you know you bring a
child into the world and a child is is
totally innocent and you the last thing
you want to do is make that child cry
hurt that child bring that child any
pain right you're spending most of your
day so that that child can be happy and
soothed and you know loving life and you
do this moment and fortunately I will
say say I don't know if this boils just
no it knows how to cut or what but you
know you give the kids like a tiny bit
of wine a little loopy snip and you're
good you eat some bagels and everybody's
fine my feeling about it really more
than anything else it wasn't necessarily
like the the let's say the true true
religious part per se as much as the the
tradition part my parents did it my
grandparents did it my great
grandparents did it and you can go a
long way back and all these people did
it and all these people are their their
descendants are still here there's a lot
of uh communities that are long gone
over the test of time and somehow these
Traditions uh LED people to being here
there must be some value in that there
must be something in that
um so that it was uh you know we ate ice
cream after that was pretty good we got
the Carvel cake which Everyone likes the
Carvel cake and uh you know I think
we're done having kids but I assume I'll
be at other more at other races
throughout throughout my life
um Anne says why do you think Mar hates
Trump so much A lot of people were
asking me this and again this is one of
those things where had we had more time
and I think I mentioned on the show that
you know there was a little clock by the
the area where we were sitting and they
kept adding time to it and I had a heart
out because I had to catch the red eye I
said to these guys I cannot miss my
flight like I'm going to ring the
freaking Bell at the NASDAQ I cannot
miss my flight but they kept extending
the time extending the time and I had
said to Phoenix right before he started
I said no matter what's happening if
we're killing each other or if this
thing's going great I got to get out of
that studio at whatever it was like 9 30
or something like that and I also didn't
plan to a drink that much I didn't plan
to smoke the weed I mean there was a lot
going on but you know right at the end
if if you haven't seen the interview yet
if you just watch the last 10 minutes
and we do some trumps stuff and this and
that and you know he he has this thing
about
um you know but Trump said grab him by
the [ __ ] and it was like you know this
was the same guy that was asking me a
lot of all questions about about anal
sex to be quite Frank
um I which I didn't care like it wasn't
something I cared to discuss
um but it's like people talk a certain
way and I think Trump's just a guy who
talks a certain way and all that stuff
he he sort of whittled it down at the
end to Trump's not conceding the
election and then when I said to Bill
well you know Hillary was saying Trump
was an illegitimate president that was
the most interesting moment politically
of the entire thing maybe not personally
but politically because I what was his
exact line do you remember he said no no
she didn't is that what it was he said
no she didn't and I said bill there's a
tweet out there there's video Blah Blah
Blah there is video you have all seen it
we could pull up the freaking tweet
right now if we wanted you can all find
the tweet and what I thought was
interesting was I I genuinely believe he
did not know
now we all have blind spots myself
included I think what I said to him
after that was I think you Bill have a
blind spot here and that's not we all
have it right we're all insulated in our
own World Views and we have to do our
best to punch beyond that and find some
things that might find us to be you know
that might be a little uncomfortable to
us or go against the narrative that
we've chosen or whatever it might be
but I think that his reaction seemed
very honest to me like he genuinely
didn't know that now that would be an
interesting thing that maybe his
producers might want to think about hey
maybe we're not we're not giving this
guy enough of the information so he has
the full picture when he's going out
there and talking about these things but
then you know we got into it sort of
about well he said to me well what's
better I said you got to admit Bill
things are better you know the economy
is better the the border is better etc
etc he he didn't lie to he didn't not
lie he didn't
um
he didn't deny that those things are
true so I think the Moment of Truth
really will come for a lot of the sort
of let's say Bill Maher type liberals
over the next two and a half weeks right
we've got this big election so if if you
watching this If you're sort of on the
fence or you've been a Democrat your
whole life you were say you let's say
maybe you were sort of like a Tulsi
person so you were a Democrat well here
we are the proof is in the pudding of
two years of Biden here we are at the
midterms and do you think this thing is
going well do you think the economy is
being run well do you think the border
is being run well what the hell do you
think is going on with Ukraine and Joe
Biden talking about Armageddon do you
think that Joe Biden is mentally fit to
be president do you think that Kamala
Harris is ready to take over I mean the
list goes on and on right we could do an
awful lot of this do you think that
endless spending just because they put a
nice name on it inflation reduction act
do you think that that actually stops
inflation all of the stuff the woke
stuff too I didn't mention any of that
so the the proof now this is the moment
of truth I suppose This Is The Moment of
Truth for those types of liberals and my
hope is that uh when it comes Wednesday
rolls around and it's post-election and
the Republicans have done really well
and hopefully taken back the house and
maybe have the Senate and there's a
feeling we can we can really change this
thing and enough's enough uh that the
Liberals will have come around and then
by the way then if you so choose to vote
Republican as an old school liberal
fight for your liberal beliefs really I
mean that I'm a guy that wrote a
freaking book defending Classical
liberalism right so fight for it but
fight for it from within a party that's
somewhat sane and functioning and then I
think just for now the Democrat Party
just has to go down with the wokes and
the Socialists and as I've said many
times maybe years from now a phoenix
rises from bashes that's kind of where
we're at I think at this point Croft
says what's everyone else drinking let's
get I want to know what more people are
drinking as long as we're doing this
Croft says Dave were you or David ever
Gamers like PC or console if what did
you do do you like to play this is a
great question thank you uh so I was a I
was a I was a huge gamer I was a gamer
man I remember getting I remember seeing
my first Nintendo Entertainment System
NES 8-bit Nintendo which I have I still
have here and it works I had to take it
apart one day watch a video on YouTube
YouTube
uh the tequila Works guys
um YouTube
um I was you know I like you know blow
in the cartridges for a while eventually
that stopped working I took the entire
thing apart rebuilt it myself like
Robocop and now my 8-bit Nintendo works
yeah you got to reset it a couple times
you got to jam the games in weird you
still have to blow sometimes and all
that but it works I remember seeing
8-bit Nintendo for the first time at my
buddy John's house it was 1985. 99 sure
it was 1985 we were we were nine years
old eight nine years old old what does
that put you in like third grade
something like that and I remember
playing Mario Brothers I could not
believe anything could be that cool or
that fun or anything and then we just we
spent years and years I mean sleepovers
hours after school old school Mario
Brothers obviously and Duck Hunt was on
the original thing to any of you any of
you remember gyromite you'll this will
blow you away Connor you're a gamer
there was a thing that Nintendo came
with this in the system something called
gyromite and it was a game that had a
little robot you had a physical robot
that you put next to your Nintendo
system and you would play a game and
then gyro might would move around and he
would do some things believe it's true
Google gyro might it's a true thing and
then you had the gun for duck hunt and
all that uh played I loved Contra me and
my brother would play Contra over and
over and over 30 men up up down down
left right left right ba select start
you guys all remember the code of course
um and then all the sports games I loved
Bases Loaded I would argue bass is
loaded too was better than Bases Loaded
one I know that's very controversial uh
Matt uh well no Madden football came a
little bit later with Sega Genesis which
Sega that was probably my Prime if
you're asking me about my Prime uh video
game years Sega Genesis now I'm in like
eighth ninth grade and Ghouls and ghosts
Sonic all the sports games NBA Live all
that kind of stuff and uh those were
those were good old days now I just
can't I can't first off I don't have
time so I know a lot of people want me
to play video games and I I have a
PlayStation two or seven or nine what do
I have down there I got a PlayStation I
think I got it four oh no of course not
two I have four Playstation four thank
you
um I have one downstairs I just don't
have time and uh I have trouble running
this way
I can run that way you know what I'm
saying I can run that way like Mario and
I can run this way even though back in
the day with Mario you couldn't the
screen would follow you and then it
would block you off but if you want me
to run that way I'm good and I can run
that way in the rare games that allow
you I think Metroid would let you run
both ways I can't run this way I can't
do it I don't know if it's a it's a
mental thing or I don't know what it is
what are people drinking right now in
the Reuben report the locals Community
we've got some Mojitos very nice I hope
you muddled the mint well a raspberry
Riesling that's very refreshing
especially if you're in a warmer climate
sounds very nice a Portuguese Vino Verde
that sounds nice uh pinot grigio with
cherry oh you know what you could do so
I'm not a I'm not a white wine guy I
don't I don't love the white wine but I
want you to enjoy white wine if you do
uh you put a little frozen fruit in
there are your cherries Frozen I'm
wondering you just throw some frozen
raspberries in there something it'll
it'll work for you seven up zero very
nice keeping it clean on this Monday
night I respect it and a Bourbon Neat
very nice very no one's no one's got the
tequila with me huh wow
does that make me an alcoholic
drinking tequila Alone on YouTube
Thomas says what was Luke's weight at
Birth Luke was 8.1 pounds and he was
born uh he was born about nine days
early so I think he was born he was due
yesterday or something but he was 8.1
and Justin I think was 7-0 but Justin's
huge this is a big hit like he's going
to be a linebacker he's he's uh you know
he's well we were able to get breast
milk we were blessed enough that we were
able to attain breast milk and also my
sister gave birth the week after Justin
so she's been able to give us some milk
so these kids are getting breast milk
which there's all sorts of nutritional
reasons why that why that's great but
when you're feeding kids out of a bottle
of breast milk usually they're getting
breast milk out of the breast it could
be a little more difficult to gauge how
much they should be eating because you
know if you fill up a bottle to say four
ounces you kind of think oh they should
drink all four ounces but when they're
going to teat they're kind of just
stopping when they don't want to anymore
or when mom's got to get up so we're
balancing a little bit about of that but
Justin's in like the 85th percentile in
height and weight and Luke's doing good
and that's all good all good uh Tony
says can we give three cheers for Daphne
being such an awesome Community manager
Daphne is your Local's name Tony did you
just
to Daphne she's doing a fine job over
there
all right Phoenix I'll allow you to
throw in a few more Oh no you're in
charge over there Daphne all right you
can throw in a few more Bizarro
questions if people want to get off
politics for a minute and uh yes things
things are pretty good oh I should also
say you know I mentioned it the other
day
um all of our channels are blowing up
right now I you know I don't know if
it's pre-election where always
pre-election that's where these type of
channels
politics culture channels they all kind
of explode but across the board YouTube
Rumble everything we're doing almost
every day now is our best day ever our
our the 28 day period we're in right now
is by far our best 28 day period
um like it's really been uh we're on a
nice little roll I would like to just
chalk that up to
um
that we're doing something decent and
maybe a little bit different I would
like to maybe also chalk that up to you
know maybe I got some of Mars old school
liberals who maybe didn't love me or
didn't know me you know I saw a bunch of
people in his comment section that
didn't know me they were like who is
this Reuben guy like he seems like a
sane conservative it's like if that's
what I am now that's just so wild but I
I guess I guess it is possible all right
a couple more and then we'll get to it
I'm roasting a nice garlic picana
tonight which I was going to do for you
guys but uh my mother-in-law it's her
last night so she's getting the picana
but I did get
that she's just getting the regular one
I got you guys for Friday night a wagyu
picana you get that fat cap on the top
you score it a little salt pepper oh
perfect perfect Tony says what is your
breakfast of champions
um I usually probably about 90 of the
time right now I'm doing uh five a zero
percent fat yogurt do some throw some
raspberries and blueberries in there a
little bit of Florida honey love that
Florida honey and some peanut butter
granola that's probably 90 of time and
then every now and again if I'm running
a little late in the morning
cleaning up poop sometimes that has to
do with the kid whatever it might be uh
it still works still works come on
um I do just grab a hard-boiled egg and
I just down it which Daphne loves that
right there's nothing you love more than
when I'm just standing there and you're
like Dave you've got to get up to the
studio and I've just got a big egg in my
mouth
that's what we're doing around here uh
Jeannie says a Democrat just handed me a
bloody mary apparently he used
apparently he used the blood of children
tastes a little coppery
where are you
are you in Hillary Clinton's house are
you on the Epstein Island where where
are you right now that that would be
happening that is that is very bizarre
but all right all right last question
and then I do hear babies crying so you
think the people can hear them through
the mic probably not right private uh
Tony says uh speaking of David are we
going to get an update on the cookbook
soon so David's been working on this
cookbook for a long long time and for
those of you that want to see beginnings
of it you can go to davidscookbook.com
or you can go to instagram.com David's
cookbook there's not a lot updated
lately because of babies and a move and
home construction and life man it's
tough however he is working on it we're
trying to figure out a way that maybe
originally he really wanted it to be a
separate thing and I fully respect that
because obviously
I'm a public person most times if we go
out or we do things like things tend to
be about me a lot actually one thing
that I really do love about fatherhood
this is I guess an ancillary benefit is
that things around the house are not
about me as much my day is about me
right oh you're interviewing this person
I'm talking to the camera you're asking
me questions like it's a lot about me
that is great to some extent and it's a
validation of what I've put into the
universe and all that but it's also like
I think to some extent like
I don't know there's like an end of that
road I guess something like that
um so the fact that these kids are
around it makes it less about me
um and David really wanted this book to
be sort of separate for me because
obviously if we put my name on it or
something it will it will sell pretty
well blah blah blah so now we're
thinking maybe just because he's so
crunched with the kids that maybe I will
have a little something to do with it it
could be the David's cookbook or
something like that but he's an
incredible Chef however I have to say
that I've taken over a bunch of the
cooking duties uh since fatherhood is
rolling around and it's it's mostly
grilling I'm mostly in the grill but I
do a freaking amazing meat sauce three
meats let it simmer for like five six
hours
um I'm doing doing a bunch of different
I make a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich that'll just knock you out and
Daphne's baking a lot these days what do
we have today
we had pumpkin chocolate chip cookies
with just a dash of pumpkin and it was
just right uh it's me Monday guys by the
way over at the locals Community this is
the one I put up this morning I saw this
this morning this is pretty great I'm
here to crash bicycles and economies
and I'm all out of bicycles
how is it possible that that man is
present in the United States man well I
hope you've enjoyed happy hour I think
we're gonna do a few more of these we're
gonna try to mix it up over the next
couple months and do some interesting
things uh we have a great I don't want
to tease too much but election night
something special is happening on
locations somewhere I probably said too
much but think about it you might be
able to put it together
um we're going to be going to DC a
little about I think the week after the
election uh we were originally going to
go the day after but we gotta we want to
kind of get the lay of the land see what
happens and who's going to be in and
about DC you know a lot of people
they leave the Senators congressmen they
leave they're supposed to spend most of
their time obviously in their home
districts but so many of them just camp
out in DC and that's where they're going
to the orgies and the all the whatever
they're doing
um and uh that's what what's his name
said and then they took him out remember
well uh yeah Madison cother and said
that next thing you know he disappeared
I have no evidence of that I don't know
it was a joke okay uh but anyway we want
to let the dust settle because most of
people go home for their races right
you're back in your state for your race
so we're going to go a week after the
election we got a studio there through
the blaze guys that's pretty awesome
actually and we have a whole bunch of
senators lined up and and we're just
going to interview as many people as
possible I'll do a couple live shows
from down there I hope so that will be
good I think I'm gonna do Tim Poole's
podcast while we're in Virginia a couple
of things on the docket so uh yes it's
uh it's all good how come you guys
didn't drink while I'm sitting here like
a drunken fool oh cause you gotta drive
you're very responsible
guys if you'd like to play along as
always
reubenreport.locals.com if you haven't
subscribed on Rumble rumble.com Reuben
report my full interview with Megan
Kelly is up across platforms right now
ad free as always at locals and I leave
you with a cold close that uh especially
if you've been drinking will make
particularly no sense see you tomorrow
there's not a single solitary Biden man
that is younger than any Biden woman
thank you